si esta audiencia duró más de cinco
horas en que los representantes los
congresistas tenían cinco minutos para
preguntarle al secretario de estado de
anthony blinken por lo que algunos
calificar el fracaso en afganistán lo
que pasa es que muchos están en campaña
y lo que hicieron varios congresistas
fue usar estos cinco minutos que tenían
de micrófono abierto en televisión
nacional en interrogación con antony
blinken para hacer una crítica y pues
lograr más votos posibles de cara a las
elecciones del 2022 acá en estados
unidos sin embargo preguntas una de
ellas la que más se repitió fue porque
se excluyó al gobierno afgano y las
negociaciones que se llevaron a cabo con
el talibán en cavar entre el gobierno
del ex presidente donald trump y el
talibán en qatar no estuvo presente el
gobierno afgano y eso fue una de las
dudas principales también qué pasó si se
tenía inteligencia militar sobre los
ataques potenciales ataques terroristas
en el aeropuerto de kabul por qué se
hizo más para evitar las muertes de los
soldados estadounidenses y tercero
también se llevó a cabo la pregunta de
qué se está haciendo para tratar de
ayudar a los 100 aproximadamente 100
estadounidenses que siguen en afganistán
para que lleguen a suelo estadounidense
sanos y salvos blinken se defendió en
varias ocasiones diciendo que
simplemente su gobierno no había
adoptado un plan
completo sobre afganistán sino que
simplemente adoptó una agenda una línea
de tiempo que ya había firmado el
gobierno anterior